with Mark Phillips who's outside st.
George's Chapel mark good morning and
again good morning well we've been
talking up until now about how different
the guest list looks up for this kind of
wedding but in two hours time when that
ceremony begins it's going to look quite
different from normal traditional royal
weddings as well there'll be a lot of
tradition in it they'll be the hymns
they'll be the prayers they'll be the
blessings they'll be the exchange of
vows of course but there will also be a
distinct American element in the
ceremony as well including in the music
and particularly including in the people
giving the service the service will be
led by the local prelate here at the at
the chapel the Archbishop of Canterbury
will in fact marry Justin Welby he will
in fact marry the couple and do the
exchange of vows but the sermon may well
be the highlight of this ceremony
because it's going to be given by the
American Episcopalian Bishop Michael
Curry who has a style that this place
has probably never heard the likes of
and I had a really interesting
opportunity to sit down with both of
them yesterday and this is what they had
to say for you Mr curry did is there
something special for you to participate
in an events like this do you see it as
inclusive in that respect that someone
like you from the American church the
American Episcopal Church being here in
the heart of the Church of England
country does that make any kind of a
difference to you
well well to be sure the Church of
England is is the mother church and and
so it's it's always to be good in Mama's
house do you see yourself the
subcarriers bringing that kind of style
the American preacher style
come on i'll break i'll you know i i'd
never forget my daddy told me when i was
fairly new as a priest he said just
always be who you really are don't
pretend to be somebody else and so a
very different kind of sermon
anticipated here certainly different
from the style that we've heard here in
the past and it'll be followed by a very
different kind of music the old classic
stand by me will be played when after as
soon as as bishop Currie has has
finished his sermon so we have that to
look forward to and what little under
two hours from now Kevin all right and
we will be right here thank you mark I
love how it says a non-traditional
version of stand by me that's code for
gospel it's gonna be a possible version
of stand by me which I love that song I
think it's beautiful that it's going to
be played at their wedding stand by me
and it's another one of the American
touches that are being added to this
ceremony that will make it special and
very different which is exactly what
they wanted it to be